each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so welcome good morning everybody it is
my great pleasure here to welcome Shiva
sin darme here from University of a
Southern California he's a PhD student
in lab of shri narayan 9 and is here to
talk to us about description based
approaches to audio information
processing he's a PhD student and he's
actually won a best paper award at a
multimedia signal processing conference
in 2006 I believe and here to tell us
about his PhD research Thanks thank you
I'd like to first welcome you all and
particularly to thank Mike cells are for
having me over to make a presentation at
Microsoft Research I'm sure a pseudonym
and my the title of today's topic with
talk of today's title of today's talk
talk would be description based all the
information processing and let me reduce
myself I've being in sri 9 in this lab
at USC I've had the opportunity to work
in variety of areas in speech and audio
processing and also publish in a variety
of things and work in a lot of projects
in speech interfaces and human-computer
interfaces are we happy to talk about
any particular project later but today's
title is description based audio
information processing which essentially
talks about multimedia content
processing and what I mean by multi
media and content is that multimedia has
three facets to it one is video audio
and text in this case a video and audio
opaque media that is if you are given a
media video or an audio document you
don't know what it contains unless you
listen to it and usually text are
associated with this opaque content to
describe what it what underlying
document has in this case of course we
can have varieties of descriptions or
tags which essentially talks about what
the content is about what it contains
and how it sounds for audio and how it
looks probably for video and
how it looks for video is not so
exciting to me at least but my main
focus is on how about audio and how it
sounds and what it contains so to go a
bit further the description based
approach essentially involves creating a
varying levels of descriptions of audio
and essentially developing automatic
processing techniques to represent and
process audio at these description
levels at the lowest level is a signal
level which is essentially the actual
audio signal you have and from the next
level would be something called
attributes which is some form of a
course low dimensional representation of
audio and above that is what I call or
what is known as automatic onomatopoeic
description where you actually talk
about how the sound sounds words like
click third thump and onomatopoeia oh it
means it's it essentially how the sound
sounds words like click yeah yeah yeah
so Third Temple aspect of a low level
information like motion stopped
information yes yes yes the that's the
detail level is ignored only thing I'm
talking about here is contact what it
contains not about Howard it but it is
essentially how it sounds more than the
actual other intricate content and at
the highest level you have the semantic
labels which is essentially things like
is a semantic labels and in conventional
content processing there's a big jump
between the signal level and the highest
semantic level labels so let me give you
a better idea of what what I'm talking
about so in this case you have a sound
clip and you have how it sounds what it
contains and watch contain varying
levels so say the sound clip is here so
if you want me the lower right corner if
if if I just give you that clip without
you can't listen to it then you cannot
really find out what it is about so let
me give you a little bit of information
so the file contains children screaming
so in this case it gives you a certain
idea of what the sound
is and what it can have but it does not
also till still tell you about how it
sounds about some perceptual qualities
of the sound so if I give you a little
bit more information say it has booing
sounds which is an onomatopoeia
description of of the audio then you
have a better idea of what the sound
contains and how it sounds so if I play
the clip now they get the idea so all
these levels are descriptions
essentially talk about one thing but at
but give you different levels of
information moving on so why are wise
perception essentially onomatopoeia
descriptions talk about perceptual
similarities and why is perception
important the first thing is the human
audition predominantly relies on
perception so when you whenever you have
a sound you have an immediate
understanding of the perceptual
qualities of the sound and in general
the semantic labels or text based
indexing only capture the high-level
semantic labels or about what the above
the content and typically ignore the
perceptual part and some examples for
multimedia which does that kind of a
which has that kind of an approach is
YouTube and Flickr which is for video
and images so but in audio we are more
interested in perception and tag based
indexing has limited use for it and for
it as of so far indexing the perceptual
similarities you want to or not only
have perceptual descriptions to it but
also be able to search through the
actual media file and the ultimate goal
of such a system was such an objective
is to create a full-duplex audio
retrieval system where you can actually
move through the varying levels of
description and also search the content
and text in equivalent ways to give you
a better idea of what I am talking about
when I say moving through content let me
give you a demo this is a simple it's an
audio retrieval system where you present
an audio clip as a query to the system
and the system retrieves queries that
are audio clips that are similar to the
presented query for an obvious example
so in this case in the top part of the
window I've loaded a library
which is the BBC sound effects library
which has a wide variety of sounds and
in here i have a list of pre-loaded
queries so let me present this query to
the system so that's the query which i
have presented and system is retrieved a
list of files which are have a switch
which are similar to the query so let me
just play this is like an obvious
example right so that's the query and
these are the most retrieved similar
clips so in this case of course the data
set has direct relevance but let me play
another say a more comp better example
which is kind of my favorite so this
case i selected say a quiet small
restaurant so you might wonder what kind
of sounds it has so a plate
so it's actually a very complicated
scene where you have people talking to
each other and you also have clattering
sounds of the dishes and other things
going on in the background so in this
case say I want to play something so in
this case it has retrieved say large
open square which actually has the same
kind of people chatting and the variety
of sounds in the background so in this
case there are there are very different
kind of perceptual similarity that
you're which has been brought about this
is kind of important when you're talking
about unstructured audio and that's kind
of the main goal in this yea sure-sure
is something we're supposed a call
center vacation we don't know where the
cooler was speaking from right I'm
wondering whether we'll be able to use
your staff with able to detect the
background know the voice you know oh is
that people involved former a story if
it was something like a while with a
phone call come see even though they
talk about something back whether you
read you'll be able to realize okay so I
you know pick on the voice it's actually
soft like a restaurant or something
actually they are the pass you know a
train station is that the possible to do
that yeah I think it's possible because
many of them play through this system
bit and I was realized that at some
points I mean the only sounds sometimes
are also mixed together so when you have
a foreground and a background thing
which are mixed together depending on
how the foreground background interplay
in the audio clip that it relieves that
kind of thing so if you train the system
in a certain way that I think it should
be able to do it yeah so one interesting
thing which also came up with this clip
which is say synthesized air raid so you
would expect some kind of an alarm going
off
alright so so so listen to the first
clip that I retrieved which is our
favorite
so this example is kind of hits hits the
point because you see in the first case
the query was synthesized air raid which
is somewhat entirely different from
children booing in terms of semantic
labels it has but in terms of perception
you can call them to be asked you can
say that they are actually similar so
that's what I'm getting at when I'm
saying a perceptual base similarities
for audio and in this case what is the
main challenge the main challenge here
is to deal with unstructured audio when
I say unstructured audio it can have
multiple sources interacting with each
other there are no domain restrictions
of what the sources can be it can be any
source of any it can have different
perceptual qualities and there are no
isolated acoustic sources in general
when you listen to any audio clip in in
any real settings then there are many
things going on at the same time so you
can't expect there are no isolated audio
clips of sound sources in this and the
main one interesting thing about
unstructured audio is that when you talk
about similarities or when you talk
about relationship between two audio
clips you could be talking about
different timescales if you remember at
different time scales it could be
something which has which is of a
particular event which happened in the
clip like a phone going off in a meeting
or it could be about the whole clip in
which case it's actually a meeting scene
or things like that so there are these
different things which you need to
figure out what people are looking for
when you talk about perception
similarities and there is this ambiguity
issue which I mentioned where we can
have different semantic labels but they
can have similar perceptual categories
perceptual qualities so the overview of
the talk is like this I'll be going
through the varieties in this pyramid
and the first thing I will talk about is
how i did that retrieval which you just
saw which is by latent perceptual
indexing and I'll also present some
classification results by categories
then I also talked about how to us how
we went about doing experiments for
assigning on a multiple tags for audio
clips which is a second part of the talk
using automatic describing audio clips
by on a might appear tags and also i'll
talk about a time-varying representation
which is somewhere here which is a
course
entation of the acoustic structure and
plus happening in an audio file so i'll
be talking about this and then finally a
present to be discussion of the work and
there is a little bit surprise for you
at the end which will hopefully will
make you laugh so first thing first I
will talk about the late in perceptual
indexing about how I did the earlier
demo how how the system works so in
layton perceptual indexing in layton
document analysis what you do is you
have a document see a text document and
which can be broken down into units or
in this case words and what you do is
you try to determine a unit document
frequency measure for each document a
given set of documents like that and
then you understand or you try to create
a relationship between the documents and
the words and essentially you can do
indexing of text documents based on that
so how it works is so you have set of
text documents on the in the rows and
you have you choose certain keywords in
the columns and you essentially try to
determine the number of times each word
occurs in each document and by singular
value decomposition of this unit
document co-occurrence matrix you can
actually map each of these text
documents into a continuous space which
is spanned by the eigenvectors of the
SVD and then you can generate a
relationship between the documents based
on our vector similarities so how do we
do the same thing for audio the for a
late in document analysis of audio there
is a fundamental limitation here the
problem is that audio inherently is
continuous thing you do not have
distinct units which like words for text
but in this case what we try to do is to
try to determine distinct units for
audio clips and when I say units it is
not necessarily distinct segments of
audio clips which makes sense it could
be anything arbitrary and once you
determine those units you can actually
have a similar unit document
co-occurrence matrix so in this case in
terms of each of them then what can i
use you
in the way from the Mayo is it red phone
it's in the transform to me yeah yeah so
in this case what we have is say you
have a whole set of audio clips and you
want to buy in a represent them in a
continuous space by late and document
analysis so you extract features by
standard frame based analysis and so you
end up with a big bag of features now if
you perform unsupervised clustering you
end up with n distinct clusters in the
audio n distinct Luster's of these audio
clips in the feature space and once you
have those clusters what you do is you
can quantize each frame that you extract
from the audio clips to one of these
clusters and you can essentially derive
a unit document co-occurrence matrix
similar to what we did for text for
audio clips and once we have that you
can do the SVD and essentially map each
of these audio clips into the latent
perceptual space where it's indexed
according where it's a perception space
which is spanned by the eigenvectors of
the SVD matrices now there are son i
would say that these clusters although i
am doing it in an unsupervised Wade
there are some things which I will talk
about it later what they mean so of
course you don't want to retrain your
system every time you have a new audio
file arising so how do you represent a
query file which is outside the training
set it you again get the query file and
you get extract the features and you
quantize each of these features into one
of these clusters and you end up with
the unit document measure again and
using the SVD matrices you can do is
have a pseudo representation in the
perceptual space and using similarity
measures you can come up with similar
clips for a given query for the text is
no variability or whatever where you
have is a fixed point yeah now in the
audio case no
there's a very busy day how do you how
does that factor yeah oh yeah your
question is in the next life so what is
semantic indexing semantic indexing do
what it does is it it has the it creates
associations with documents based on the
unit document occurrence and the main
idea here is to reduce the noisiness and
language what i mean by noisiness in
language is that the same word can
represent different concepts or
different concepts can be represent by
the same word depending on context
that's the kind of noise which you try
to reduce that SVD and in the case of
audio what we do is we try to reduce the
variations in the acoustic sources since
if since the whole idea is to do it for
unstructured audio where sources can be
record the same source can be recorded
in different settings so they will have
different perceptual qualities but also
there can be other overlaps overlaps
with other sources which again will
causes variations and you can actually
reduce the noise based by SVD and that's
the kind of noise which are trying to do
the variations in the acoustic sources
and in the fur in the semantic indexing
case you try to map discrete objects
which is save words and text into a
continuous space and in the case of
perceptual indexing you actually
explicitly discover units in audio and
then you map it into the continuous
space and you can have similarity
measures in both these spaces how low is
the unit is done in an unsupervised
manner so it can be it can be anywhere
from one frame to hundreds of frames
yeah so it's not predetermining they
don't necessarily mean a particular
unique audio event they could be a
beginning of a clap or it could be one
half of phoneme if you want it could be
anything so it depends here is your
engines minister so when you say that is
that mean you actually explicitly
searching all years and so
into doing frame-by-frame classification
than just adjacent things global same
cluster its frame by frame
classification so once you know where
once which cluster one frame belongs to
that's a quantization step you can and
then you know that each audio clip has
saved five hundred or five thousand
frames then you can come up with the
unit document measure for that that's
how it's done yeah but there is no like
frame interframe merging or things
involved it's just you for this part at
least it's just been done directly so
for the experiments so for this system
to test the system we went with this of
course the frame based analysis where we
use 14 dimensional vectors 12 mel
frequency capsule coefficients with
spectral centroid and the spectral role
of frequency which are commonly used in
audio classification task and the data
set here is again we are looking at
unstructured audio so the data set used
here is generic sound effects library
the BBC sound effects library where the
audio clip can vary from a few seconds
to a few minutes the thing here is that
there is no predetermined like duration
of audio clip for measuring the
similarity we can have any arbitrary
duration and it's not domain-specific
and completely unstructured so
evaluation strategies to evaluate such a
system for unstructured audio it's kind
of tricky and so we perform our set to
two sets of experiments one is so one is
for it so if going back to the full
duplex aspect of retrieval system you
can have queries by text and queries by
example and you want to see
classification errors for the
classification rates for these things or
retrieval rates for these things so in
this case we have example based
retrieval and example based retrieval
and take spaced retrieval text based
retrieval is by LSI for example based
retrieval we do an additional thing
where we do actually subjective test
where people listen to the audio clips
and see if it's relevant to the query or
not in that case they listen to the
query and listen to the top five of the
queries and see if it's relevant or not
and
that's for the audio trips you just
listen to yeah sound sound effects
library yeah like unionism with
instructions yeah so and then another
set of fact thing which was done
automatically was to see category wise
classification or retrieval rates where
you had we split the same audio data set
into semantics and onomatopoeia have the
same data set with semantic labels and
onomatopoeia labels and see how well
query by example and query by text works
for that case the first is of course the
perceptual evaluation which is the
subjective experiments is done here so
it essentially measures the ability of
the system to retrieve perceptually
similar clips and it's difficult to
measure it automatically because there
is no correct definition of a correct
retrieved clip so to do that we did it
manually where we had seven subject
listen to about 100 query files and for
each of the hundred query files they had
to listen to the top five retrieved
clips by and determine if any of those
top five are relevant or similar to the
query or not and this was done using web
page gy and the results of the
perception evaluation in this case what
we measure is it is an empirical
probability measure where you measure
the probability of retrieving c or more
clips which in see in this case goes
from one to five this is a top five
retrieved clips and that's the solid
line which you see and the dotted line
you see is the probability of retrieving
no clips so none of the top five were
actually were actually relevant to the
given query so as a result shows a
result show that the probability of
retrieving at least one clip is about at
least one relevant clip is about point
75 and retrieving at least two clips is
about Oh point five it really no
relevant clips is reasonably low so
that's kind of a good result here and
this was people listening to the album
system by phone system yeah so they
listened to the given query
and then they listen to the top five of
the return clips and then if any of the
top which are which one of the top five
are relevant or similar to the query
clip they just mark it as yes or no
normalized all then so you also ran the
experiment where instead of your system
you had a random sampling return to the
user so you could see what was the prior
for the database of returning a relevant
clip in the top five I know that that
form of say I would say the ABX kind of
thing where you can also do that that
wasn't done here no it's actually quite
tedious because it take it took about
name maybe a little over an hour for
each person to do it so I don't know if
you can it it might you have to do for
the same queries and there are issues of
bias if you get into it maybe you could
do it for a smaller set of clips if
possible but it's kind of open how you
want to do it I mean each has its
advantages it is lotta juice right I'm
from just from this graph I don't see
any convincing evidence not knowing the
data set that your system is better than
random selection five tips what is the
problem to have one of them is
perceptually relevant by by any user
that's true yeah that's a good point
yeah yeah yeah I should probably have
done that but it yeah he could have done
that yeah what's that mean I guess
brother will be drawn because and I
needed to just like the interactions
have any given diffuser so like I can
easily integrate layers coconut before i
buy the air raid siren and you got back
to me like this children oh yeah yeah so
those are acoustically similar yeah but
you know but perception invokes all
sorts of other no let some grout that's
air me you're not throwing cool this is
like what so if this was this was
actually left open to the people they
would whatever they deemed similar you
could any way in any way they they
wanted they can they can either say know
that nothing's even if for the array
they might be expecting some kind of
side
now it sounds but if booing is relevant
or not that's all open to them if they
want to see so it's a very difficult
thing to determine if it yeah so that's
seven more question sure to grab Chuck
this a dotted line in 0.25 can you
explain is that new gurkel number or
yeah okay so how do you get that oh uh
it's essentially the number of times
none of the clips were actually and none
of the five top five were actually
tagged as relevant to the quay ok so
this ok yeah so that's the mass that's
not in the rest of the graph ok I think
I understand yeah so the next experiment
that was done was to do category wise
retrieval where the categories were
again perceptual categories and semantic
categories the perceptual categories
were used was done using onomatopoeia
labels words like bang boom things like
that and then you also have semantic
labels which is say office both those
kind of sounds and both these test cases
were done for the BBC sound effects
library about 2,400 kids were used in
each case and so in this case of course
the retrieval was measured for both text
based queries and example based queries
and the results are done accordingly so
the first result is of course the query
by example where I present queries or
queries of audio clips presented to the
system and the system retrieves similar
clips in this case the blue line which
you see is the retrieval rate for the
onomatopoeia categories and the red line
you see is the retrieval you see for the
semantic categories in this case of
course they're reasonably close to each
other and next case is the query by text
where I present the text queries to the
system and in this case if you see that
the red line actually jumped the red
line is by semantic labels and the
onomatopoeia case which is the blue line
is somewhat the same as the previous
query by example case what essentially
it points to is that the semantic I'll
get to the conclusion later
so in conclusion what we have done here
is that in a single vector
representation for a knowledge Asher ah
no actually should uh sure yeah no I
should want to explain that better so in
this data set right you have audio clips
and then you have the text description
of the audio clips like that's yeah yeah
yeah like say four-minute warning
alright so if I present that as a query
to the system which is a text query I do
the classification according to the
labels on it so that full minute warning
alert is probably saw part of the
industry semantic label and it's also
part of say who tour part of
onomatopoeia label so yes yes yes yes so
it's a it's yeah it's it's it's like the
first clip which I played where you have
one clip then you have onomatopoeia
booing kind of sound and then you have
the text label to it which is the
category so children sound so if I say
give the query like children crying or
children screaming it will retrieve
whether it retrieves a booing sound for
it or whether and that's one case that's
onomatopoeia label case and the other
case is whether it retrieves belonging
to the same category I think children
sound belongs to domestic sounds and if
it retrieves clips which belong to this
that's a semantic category which are
looking at is that clear or
so that's the result so the the thing
which amp which I was trying to conclude
here was that it's essentially points to
the fact that of text queries are better
represent semantic labels more than
onomatopoeia labels which are
essentially perceptual categorization of
audio so in this work what you're done
is create a single vector representation
for a whole audio clip which is which
can have arbitrary duration and it's
also scalable in form of language
descriptions lattice onomatopoeia a
description or high-level semantic
labels and also and it addresses the
content processing idea for audio
without individually identifying sources
present in a clip and this is ideal for
ideal idea for unstructured audio and
large audio processing systems and some
points to ponder is that example queries
are inherently spread when I say example
query the whole audio clip for said
three minutes is a query so it can have
a variety of different sources in it in
different times so it's actually very
spread in terms of in the perceptual
space so it's a very spread thing which
are actually giving the system the
system is trying to do it retrieve clips
that are similar to it so it's
inherently a very difficult thing to do
and in terms of text queries you can be
very specific based on your description
so it's kind of easier and one thing of
course is of course how I choose a
cluster in this case the clusters were
chosen with unsupervised clustering and
also you can also determine how many
clusters do you want those kind of
questions can be erased and also you can
try to do a try to do it with supervised
clustering if I know some clips there
are some audio clips which are have
similar categories can I put them
together and use those as clusters for
the unit document of matrix can I do
that that's kind of thing which I later
I did which I done also and you can also
do partial matching or even this is LSA
based approach which is you can also do
other things like pls a and you can also
try to develop a time varying
representation
the next part is of course you will ask
how do you do how do you actually go
about describing audio clips with
onomatopoeia attacks there are no date
ready data set available for this case
so how do you go about doing that that's
probably what I that's what I'll talk
about and also try to come up with
clustering methods for different
clustering methods based on these
onomatopoeia labels that's somewhat in
the middle of the triangle here so the
idea here is the cluster audio clips
using onomatopoeia labels and words like
click thump thud bird which are
representative of the sound itself so
the idea here is to do perceptual
characterization of clips and have
clustering based on word level
relationship and domain I of course the
main objective for this work is to build
a content ontology is to have a way to
build the content ontology where you can
compute in terms of words and signal
level measures when I say continent
ology what I mean is that say you have
so every sound that is created is
because something happening to a
particular object so if you can actually
have relationships a clock go when alarm
when the clock the alarm of the clock
goes off we can have descriptions like
ring and thing and say door and you
could door opening and closing have
certain qualities to it and knocking has
percept some qualities to it so you can
build a big structure like this for
having some form of semantic information
extraction which can be used for say
document retrieval or pervasive
computing applications so why is
clustering by onomatopoeia the
description important why is it
interesting well it's the description of
sound as i said is primarily based on
perception and there are ambiguity
issues when you talk about just
semantics labels because many clips with
different semantic labels can belong to
the same perceptual category and this is
also useful for the full duplex
retrieval system which we have where you
can have a tag based retrieval which can
have different scales of description say
onomatopoeia labels or semantic labels
and you can do retrieval for both these
cases so what we have what we are trying
to do here is again if you have say
audio clips you already have the sound
effects library which has
is given labels to it and the idea here
is to assign appropriate labels to each
of these audio clips and cluster them
accordingly using word level
relationship first thing is of course a
tagging procedure so here we have a
whole set of audio clips in and we have
people listen to this audio clips was
done using a web based GUI and they had
a list of onomatopoeia words and they
could they had the task given was to
choose for each clip they listened to
they had to choose onomatopoeia any
number of onomatopoeia words that best
describe the sound that Jesus listened
to so they could do that and they did
that and you essentially end up with
audio clips and labels associated with
this audio clips and in this case we are
doing word level clustering of these or
eclipse to do word level clustering you
need to have some idea of how similar
two words are how different they are for
that we use this method where I say you
have two words o 1 and 0 2 and you pass
it through a thesaurus then a similarity
measure can be done by having by
counting the number of words that the
thesaurus generates for each of these
words and that is kind of the number of
common words and by dividing by the
total number of words it generated you
can have a similarity measure and
distance is the one minus a similarity
so for a whole given list of words you
can have each word described in terms of
other words so you have this kind of
matrix and by PCA you can again map
these words to a continuous space to end
up with the vector representation for
each of these words because it's a
square matrix in this case and it's kind
of fool it's not yeah oh so of course we
are trying to cluster in that space and
you can have clustering fit measures
like bi c and so how does this
clustering look like so here's an
example which is mapped to two
dimensions a lot of words what I'll
bring your attention to is save words
like sizzle
phys and vis they all cluster together
and was like clang and clack they
clustered together and they form also
unique clusters in some ways this is
meaningful because words it's why are
these what what what is this clustering
tendency of these words tell us one is
that words within clusters have
overlapping meaning and for onomatopoeia
case this overlapping meaning are
amounts to having similar perceptual
qualities and words in different
clusters are sufficiently distinct and
the proposed metric is work
satisfactorily to distinguish these
differences and of course if you have
these form of grouping of words you can
essentially talk you can describe both
general and all specific properties of a
given sound clip and this is desirable
for unstructured audio I will give you
some examples of automatically derived
word clusters was like save vis and buzz
the cluster and words like zing zoom
those kind of things cluster together
and so based on those word clusters you
can ask yourself two questions one is
can acoustic signal measures qualify the
onomatopoeia words which is in general
it's popular to do frame based analysis
and that's what this experiment involves
and the second question is if you have
multiple types for the same audio clip
how do you represent it in that space
and how do you cluster them in that
space so for the first question is we
have data set where you have clips and
appropriate onomatopoeia words
associated with it and you assign
features extracted from the clips to
each of these clusters and run
classification experiments in this case
we stuck with a Gaussian map with LD
linear discriminant analysis to check
the linear separability of these case
these words in the feature space so if
classification error is low then it's
good if it's not bad so XP results of
that experiment is of course what we
realize is that some words are well
represented by this kind of frame based
analysis others are not essentially this
tells us that each onomatopoeia many
onomatopoeia tags they represent the
information at different levels of
varying scales of time
and for the second case where you are
trying to represent words with multiple
cats you can get that by say a simple of
vector addition of the individual
vectors for a given tag and standard
ones that many people lose no we have
there's no such a database for this were
cleared lang tayo sa yeah so what if
they have to take some music who doesn't
be gone through all this description Oh
piece of news ah we haven't dealt with
music in this way but we have done the
next work will actually talk about Mir
applications where we're done working
that yeah but yeah yeah yeah yeah and
yeah so but this is like also in terms
of a we have 87 words so you can be
really specific about what kind of
sounds there are so we also have a
little coarser measure which we'll talk
about in the next part of the workplace
some let yourself and improve auto
speech follow amusing another thing that
had austerity Oh Sam that's true in this
case of course we had some parts of
speech of conversations which were
tagged with murmur like murmur sounds or
a yapping yak those kind of words Hunter
what they have some somebody's making
something you know he yeah he looks like
categories on the sergeants wife a son
some when you save over there that's
true so many actually when we did the
experiments many other sounds that are
not used at the end because we couldn't
use it because they were intact because
they couldn't find proper tag for it
yeah you're right so in this case of
course if you have similar tags to two
different audio clips then they will lie
in the same area of the space and you
can cluster them accordingly so this is
the clustering experiments for the
vector representations you can see how
they can essentially see examples of how
they cluster together and what kind of
tags were assigned to them so things
like say doorbell and signal equipment
warning sounds they're all flustered and
so it's this is of course based on word
level clustering
so if you are interested I said the p.i
seem so I said there's a be a be IC
measure which we use for deciding the
number of clusters in this case it's
about 212 so conclusions the main aspect
of this work has been to tag our clips
with onomatopoeia words labels and this
is perceptually less ambiguous although
it may create semantic ambiguities but
it is useful to represent both generic
and specific properties of all you and
it's this kind of meta level this is
desirable in a meta-level representation
of audio and you can send you can use
this to annotate a medium that cannot
represent audio if you remember comic
books words like bang or represent
explosions or gunshots so you can use it
for that some points to ponder is there
are there is a fundamental
inconsistencies in understanding the
meaning of words we did the same tagging
experiments with people whose first
language was not English these
onomatopoeia words which I've used are
specific to English so we did the same
experiments with people whose first
language is not English and they came up
with entirely different descriptions so
that's one thing and the second thing is
of course even within people who use who
have english as a first language it was
hard to quantify this word to sound
mapping how different is third from a
thump can you quantify such a difference
but they are similar but that is similar
to thump more than third is similar to
say buzz office right so how do you but
how do you quantify these things and
some words such as crack you say
represent long-term signal properties
and which is not easily derived with the
existing signal frame based analysis the
final third part of the work is mainly
have a course of representation are more
and to derive a time varying time
varying vector for a audio clip and
which is then this low dimensional it's
essentially a low dimensional
representation where you can have which
is which gives you an idea of the
structure of the audio clip and perform
segmentation and classification in this
in the experiments here so the idea here
is of course you have say the
onomatopoeia words which we had and they
all we all see saw that they clustered
in a certain way and in this case if you
actually look at it closer you can see
that many of these a onomatopoeia attack
they talk about noise like say sounds
some of them talk about say harmonically
rich sounds and some of them talk about
speech like sounds and by having this
form of course of grouping which is
somewhat supervised you can derive a
time-varying representation which will
work talk about which is somewhat in
between the onomatopoeia tagging and the
signal level measures and so the
categories here are speech like sounds
harmonic and noise like sounds the
speech like sounds are say individual
crowd conversations laughter sounds
noise like sounds are interesting
because you can have anything matings
can be determined to be noise say waves
on a seashore is noise like and again
machine tools are also noise like so you
group them together based on perceptual
properties of course this this grouping
is it's kind of interesting because it's
sufficiently distinct from each other
and they are also somewhat generic any
given clip or any given audio scene will
have one or more of these things
happening together and this is also
discernible using available acoustic
features so the objective is to derive a
quantitative measure and the application
here is of course music information
retrieval for where first experiment is
to determine salient sections of a song
and the second experiment is to actually
do Sondra classification of popular
music songs and you can use it for a
variety of applications say annotation
playlist generation or even a bra quick
browsing through the media so I to give
you a better idea of what I am talking
about here's a little demo so what we
have here is a music clip and the
other tracks you see below the first one
is the speech like activity rate the
second one is the harmonic and the third
one is noise like let me play it for you
a way to tell so what you do a single
star thing the speech like activity rate
goes up so this kind of representation
it kind of gives you an idea of what's
going on in the clip and it's a huge
it's another somebody a human readable
format so the idea is to use these and
see how well you can do music
information address music information
retrieval problem each like claw to go
up try and chill girl 7a she started ah
stay there well it's actually a farm
which we doing that time averaging over
a window of about 500 milliseconds so
that's what causes the lag alright so
what we saw there was that when the when
the song was playing piano music
initially it played her the harmonic
activity it was high and when the singer
begins to sing the speech like activity
rate was high and when the drum snares
were happening the others noise like
sounds are going on so how we did this
was get features frame-based by frame
based analysis you get features from the
audio clips and you send it through a
bank of classifiers and that that what
it derives so each of these classifiers
are trained to determine if a given
frame is speech like sound noise like
sounds odd harmonic sounds and then you
do a post processing where which is the
time averaging in this case and we get
that form of representation which I just
showed you so of course it's a segmented
audio here but we also do classification
using that representation or i told i
told you earlier that these things the
groupings are interesting because they
are well separated even in the feature
space this experiment is to actually see
how well they are separated in this case
we used mfc she's our delta and delta
delta features and you can see that the
confusion matrix is close to identity
which is desirable in this case
one thing to note here is that the
training set is from the sound effects
library which is completely different
from the target here which is 67 full
length songs from i extracted from CDs
so the training set is different from
the testing set so the training set is
used to get the waveform this is view
yeah no no this is only for the
different attributes which is a speech
like sounds that this is the
classification between those categories
music no this is frame based
classification this has nothing to do
with the music so I will be talking
about the music yeah i mean this
particular yes yeah yeah so the two
experiments one is the segment vocal
sections in popular music songs and in
this case we compared manual a
segmentation again such a data set is
not available so we had to compare
manual segmentation with automatic
segmentation and we did tried it with
four different genres over 67 tracks and
for the genre classification case we
have the data set available which is
through magnitude calm they let you
download the content unless as long as
you're not doing it for other purposes
using it for sharing up but in this case
the labels were used for five jungle
labels were used and these were directly
available from the data set and the idea
to have the idea which was used for
these experiments is that these were
taken as a particular case of say
classification or segmentation of
complex axis acoustic scenes in this
case it's the music information
retrieval problems so two segments vocal
sections I went through empirical
derivation and we ended up with a rule
based segmentation rule where if you
have say s greater than zero the
segmentation is vocal section where you
can have SS speech like minus harm
noise like a sound and here are the
results you can see that the false alarm
and the error rates are reasonable hour
low which is good in this case and of
course in certain there are certain in
this case to the time instance of
segmentation has been given a little bit
of freedom you can do it within if it's
you're using mfcc trimeter for custom in
order to come up with a segment oh no
mfc seas are used so what you say each
clip you sent you exactly mfcc from that
it's all me sir salute legal yes so let
me go back to this diagram so you have
music coming in from there you do the
windowing and mfcc extraction and then
the training part of these classifiers
are those speech like a harmonic like
and lifelike sounds so that's the class
training part of these classifiers
sochi's yes yes this expensive yes I say
okay okay but then where do you
determine once yes oh that's what that
because a rule that we derive yeah so it
says in this case we have a rule well we
have a threshold and if it's above the
threshold we can start saying that this
is a secondary yeah the labels did you
handle it as my hand yeah these are kind
of lame footballs and they had these
were used the done using how you do it
for speech for say using spectrogram and
these are hand labeled unmarked so the
mark marking was done by hand and then
the automatically generated labels were
compared with these layer labels to see
if they are matching up or not and for
that case of course there was about a
one-second window which was allowed like
point five four star point 5 4 n because
we are doing a time averaging excuse me
would the number be fair so so classical
assume there is no bubbles but you could
have a false alarm yeah it could be a
very high false alarm
or it actually well what happened was I
think it came out to become sometimes it
comes out to be completely negative
which little bit of high parts in the in
the I mean it's there are errors in the
in that representation scheme so
notwithstanding those errors you could
say their plates pretty good yeah i mean
but the problem with classical is of
course you don't have hand labels also
in many cases unless I guess so Glasgow
Samantha's I'm just wondering how your
the rules do under you know you know
very harmonic music that has no there
are no right so this Gary there's no
yeah most class yeah so yeah here's what
that I think that we didn't do that
experiment and it's the idea was to see
whether you could use that
representation scheme to do such an
approach that a problem yeah yeah so
sure the final rule yeah if you have
three classifiers speech harmonic noise
the semiconductor sense is this and just
normalize it the semiconductor is this
means that this final rule is just if s
is more than 50 per cents in this case
you could say that but the thing is this
final rule was derived after a time
averaging so you could let's see so you
could you could probably say that
because but we are considering a window
of save point five seconds so it depends
on the number of windows in that thing
yeah it's just whether something's book
Allah do some simple as you can see what
thanks to just what's wrong aah now i
didn't get you over here yeah you know
you want to see whether that particular
signals of Oklahoma just yeah i mean
this much easier and probably more
accurate method in specialized are you
yes yes but yeah you're right but the
objective here was to see if you have
that kind of representation where i have
so that time varying description i
showed you right let me just go back to
this demo so what this tells you is it
is kind of like you're talking you're
describing that particular given clip in
terms of these known categories so
you're talking about the one of those
thing are they are normally actually
individually then analyzed individually
so this individual yes so this may not
be one at any moment between those three
I can we have them all three of them to
be zero for example I hope speech not
come on you can not know his life yeah
it was this 10 is it's it's it's 0 but
in this case it's one against all kind
of classification it's so you can always
get one thing on the other so you cannot
actually just sigh silence part was let
me show you that again yeah actually the
silence part was treated separately or
maybe I took it out here yeah so
essentially that silence part was done
using energy threshold
so we are done with the sex segmentation
part and second thing was to see is if
you could do a classification of music
clips genre classification of music
clips using this form of representation
of course in this case we did set of
experiments and what I will show you is
to use a are in this case AR is the
representation scheme or activity
representation scheme so AR with a
classifier and mfcc is used directly as
a classifier and the idea here is that
when you use activity rate it's used as
a mid-level representation scheme so it
is like a course representation of the
acoustic structure and you are throwing
out a lot of signal level details
information and the idea of using mhmmm
is to keep still have those detailed
signal level information and to see
whether you can still perform
classification with just that low
dimensional representation instead of
the high dimensional signal level
representation of em FCC's which is both
detailed in time and say frequency
resolution first result is of course of
the mfcc and hmm based classifier which
gave their best results and if you can
see that there are some differences in
the class-based differences one is of
course the rock pop songs were most
confused with the metal which is kind of
consistent with all the systems in there
in other systems and and the baseline is
of course about twenty percent here this
is the more interesting results which we
got from the activity rate low
dimensional representation as you can
see it's actually well above the
baseline which is chance and it's in
some cases it performs as well as the
mfcc in HMMs but in most cases it
doesn't but the idea here is to show
that see it performs much better than
baseline so it has enough information in
it to do classification and again you
can find some interesting things one is
that the metal is most
with rock which is again the same thing
and vice versa and also the classical is
acting yeah classical is most confused
with ambient sounds which again doesn't
have much local parts in it or other
instrumentations so in conclusion the of
course the best performance we got from
mfcc and hmm Bayes classifier which
which has information of the detailed
signal level measures however for the
generic framework presented to measure
the acoustic structure the is comparable
it is actually comparable to human
performance and the activity rate plus
hmm based classifier cave results which
is well about chance level and it
essentially implies that it contains
enough information to do sonra
classification which is a special case
of classifying complex acoustic scenes
and some points to ponder this is what
the method presented here is an
alternative method to coarsely measure
an acoustics structure of a given scene
and that is also interest in the
community in the MIR community to see
how non-musicians listen to music
non-musicians do not have notion of
cards and notes so how do they listen to
music and how do they appreciate music
this probably this kind of work alludes
to that question as an answer to that
question that's the kind of end of the
talk but i will let me just go with a
conclusion a little bit first of what i
presented was late in perceptual
indexing or where i seek a single vector
representation for complex for
unstructured audio and we we tested the
system for query by example and query by
text and also a two forms of
categorization based on semantic labels
and onomatopoeia labels and the then we
also saw how to see how to tag
onomatopoeia labels to give an audio
clips and how do we cluster in those who
cluster those labels and finally
represented a time varying attribute
based representation for a for a given
audio clip and essentially have spanned
through these different scales of
description for audio
and so finally so that those are the
things and one thing which is of which
you can say empirically you can conclude
is that the semantic labels asus is to
cognition is same as onomatopoeia labels
and auditory perception to probably put
it in the GRE test but so the idea is to
see that although the cognate cognitive
organization organization of humans with
objects is what the semantic labels
actually represent and in this case we
start off with the auditory perception
how do you organize auditory perception
into categories and onomatopoeia labels
is probably the answer to it and the
ultimate goal of course is to develop a
full-duplex indexing a processing system
where you could move from different
levels of descriptions and different
time scales and I can do query and
retrieval in both these domains some
applications for this work would be in
social computing where you have tags
associated with a variety of multimedia
objects and you can also use it for
browsing and interactive media
applications such as downloadable
content TiVo applications I are and
on-demand applications also you can use
this for say things like spoken
multimedia document retrieval or even
playlist generation for some desktop
applications so essentially you
revisited a variety of the basic process
of clustering segmentation and
classification methods and you can
essentially generate a derive a variety
of user centric applications for these
finally I as I promised or I hope this
part makes you laugh this is actually
related to other work which I have done
which is in speech synthesis and also
some work which I've done a special
audio particularly i will talk about a
nice project which was automatic
synthesis of human-like laughter for so
in this this is really unrelated to the
thesis work but some
which I have done in between so the idea
was to for emotional speech synthesis
you will also like to synthesize other
non linguistic utterances so for this
case we focused on automatic synthesis
of human-like laughter in the plot on
the right you see is the is the blue
plot is actually in a laughter clip
recorded and the so you can see that
there are two pi there are two things in
it one is that it has an overall
temporal property and second thing is
that there are individual calls in it so
so there are two aspects to it the
overall temporal the individual calls we
capture it using the general synthesis
analysis by synthesis and modeling
techniques and the overall temporal
property we model it using a mass
attached to a spring which is a damped
simple harmonic motion so by varying the
spring constant or the mass or the
damping factor you can generate a
variety of temporal patterns and so
there are some examples oh that's true
actually but even if you have individual
laughter from actual people it sounds
very strange shape because we set up so
you get laughter that'll be nice so so
this was essentially it's Patience's
that i work and go that's it thank you
for your time
what it is you found this kind of off
the laptop Allahu i know i think it was
NSF from here and the if I'm right I
hope my advisors corrects me later but
the other part where were agencies were
DHS or if US Army variety of any
security uh well III don't know yeah so
I don't exact product of my advisors
right belong to but there was a funding
for audio information music retrieval
applications yeah so thank you
you